[Musique]
bonsoir vendredi 3 avril bienvenue sur
tv soixante dix huit pour cette nouvelle
édition spéciale
la crise sanitaire du coronavirus
toujours au coeur des préoccupations en
france et dans les yvelines le qu'ovide
19 a fait 137 morts dans les hôpitaux du
département d'après les derniers
chiffres publiés hier soir par santé
publique france ce qui représente 18
décès supplémentaires en 24 heures huit
cent trente sept personnes étaient
hospitalisées hier sur le territoire
yvelinois 180 a placé en réanimation des
retours à domicile suite à
l'amélioration de l'état de santé se
sont également produits à 3 194 reprises
depuis le début du confinement mis en
place il ya 18 jours 31000 contrôles ont
été effectués par les forces de l'ordre
dans le département et 2900 ont donné
lieu à des verbalisations un chiffre qui
est en baisse dernièrement lé contrôle
qui vont se renforcer ce soir et pendant
tout le week end à l'occasion du début
des vacances de printemps le premier
ministre edouard philippe a été clair
aucun départ en congé n'est pas prévoir
il faut respecter les mesures de
confinement est les précisions du préfet
des yvelines sur le dispositif
interrogé par patrick jacques de dixmude
et nicolas landry je ne vous dis pas ou
parce que c'est c'est le principe même
de la dissuasion mais il y aura des
contrôles que les gens comprennent je
les dis notamment avec vous il ya
quelques jours le confinement s'est pas
l'organisation de grandes vacances c'est
tout à fait autre chose
donc oui il y aura des contrôles les
membres du corps préfectoral avec les
policiers les gendarmes et prendront pas
juré je répète que les gens résistent à
la tentation des grandes vacances
juste avant le début des vacances
scolaires lycéens de première et
terminale ont appris une nouvelle pour
le moins importante s'il n'y aura pas
des preuves écrites du baccalauréat en
fin d'année le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanc tiers a
précisé le dispositif ce matin à la
place la note du bac sera attribuée sur
la base de la moyenne dans chaque
matière obtenue aux premier et deuxième
trimestres
l éco efficience ont maintenu les notes
à distance donnée pendant le confinement
ne compteront pas en revanche si les
cours reprennent les élèves
travailleront jusqu'au 4 juillet et les
devoirs rendus seront aux prises en
compte pour l'obtention du diplôme pour
les pros
hier le bac de français est annulé pour
l'épreuve écrite mais l'épreuve orale et
bien maintenues enfants ce qui concerne
les élèves de 3e le brevet des collèges
sera délivrée sur la seule base et sur
la seule foi du livret scolaire et le
coronavirus sévit toujours dans les
yvelines avec des cas graves et des
décès en augmentation la crise sanitaire
qui se muent également peu à peu en
crise économique de quoi susciter
l'inquiétude des entreprises de toutes
tailles
écoutez ce témoignage d'une gérante d'un
institut de beauté bazerbes montigny le
bretonneux
je m'appelle christine schaer l'institut
de beauté ce la commune de montigny le
bretonneux depuis huit ans maintenant
avec ces familles ma salariés
aujourd'hui je rencontre énormément de
problèmes liés à l'épidémie du
coronavirus j'ai dû fermer mon
établissement depuis le 16 mars
maintenant je te mettre ma salariés au
chômage partiel sauf que quand vous
essayez de vous connecter le site est
saturé j'ai une personne au téléphone
qui m'a dit que c'était tout à fait
normal que j'avais à peu près 30 jours
pour le faire et dans deux ou trois
jours
sachant que j'ai une perte
d'exploitation à hauteur de 65 % de mon
chiffre d'affaires je ne sais même pas
comment je vais pouvoir lui verser son
salaire et je sais pas quand est-ce que
je vais pouvoir avoir son remboursement
comme le gouvernement nous le promet on
nous propose aussi une aide de 1500
euros à condition d'avoir perdu 70% de
son chiffre d'affaires sauf que j'en ai
perdu 65 donc les 1500 euros je n'y ai
pas le droit je ne sais même pas qui
et comment je vais pouvoir me rémunérer
moi aussi puisque à ce jour
en compensation des salaires que je me
versait rien n'est proposé et je vis
seule avec mon fils qui va avoir trois
ans moitié on nous propose aussi une
suspension de charge et de nous orienter
vers nos banques afin de souscrire un
crédit
mais dans quelles conditions on va
réouvrir enfin dans quelles conditions
je vais ouvrir ma société est ce que je
vais pouvoir continuer à avoir le
exactement le même chiffre d'affaires
qui va me permettre de rajouter une
charge supplémentaire tel qu'un crédit
ça je ne sais pas du tout aujourd'hui je
suis très inquiète et je sais pas du
tout ce que ma société va devenir et
depuis l'envoi de ce témoignage qui
remonte au début de semaine le seuil
pour être éligible à une est de 1500
euros a été revu pour le mois d'avril il
faut désormais enregistrer une perte de
50% de son chiffre d'affaires pour
pouvoir obtenir cette aide financière
est d'autres dispositifs sont en place
notamment en faveur du commerce de
proximité à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie d'ile-de-france a lancé
j'aime mes commerces à domicile
il s'agit d'un outil de référencement et
d'information sur les boutiques en
capacité de livrer et d'assurer la vente
à emporter et ce pour chaque commune
l'idée est de pouvoir afficher la liste
de ces commerces sur les sites des
mairies pour poser vos questions un
centre d'appel d'urgence est en place
pour les entreprises et les commerces en
difficulté le numéro qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
face à cette crise économique les
banques aussi sont source de solutions
pour les entreprises elles peuvent les
accompagner dans leurs démarches
elle est conseillée mais aussi agir
directement sur leur trésorerie
les explications dans ce reportage de
nicolas landry les banques au chevet des
entreprises face à la crise sanitaire
dans cet établissement près de 1700 pme
ont été contactés dans les yvelines
la priorité l'écouté le conseil des
chefs d'entreprise d'abord leurs
principales préoccupations comme
l'anneau d'ailleurs ce fut leurs
collaborateurs
donc comment les mettre en sécurité
comment organiser le chômage partiel
derrière leur priorité c'était la
trésorerie malheureusement le chiffre
d'affaires diminuant fortement voire
s'arrêter brutalement les charges
continuant il nous faut autoriser des
découvertes qui vont au delà des
autorisations classique
face aux interrogations aux difficultés
les banques proposent aussi aux
entreprises de reporter les échéances
des crédits déjà en cours dès dès les
premiers moments de cette crise
sanitaire nous avons décidé en fait de
mettre en place les reports d'échéances
donc ça c'est un gros travail qui est
dit mise en place de puits et maintenant
deux semaines et demie au crédit
agricole d'île de france plus de 500
report d'échéance de crédit ont été
demandées dans les yvelines
et puis les banques en plus des pme et
tpe peuvent être également en soutien
des grands comptes le groupe bmw france
est implanté dans le département son
siège est à saint quentin en yvelines
le site bmw distribution et lui à vélizy
villacoublay l'activité qui est bien sûr
fortement impacté avec la crise du coc
vie de 19
écoutez le directeur général de bmw
distribution tous nos sites y compris
notre siège social à vélizy est fermé
depuis le 17 mars à 12 heures toutes les
activités dans commercial ventes de
véhicules neufs d'occasion et
après-vente et pièces de rechange nous
avons zéro activité depuis cette date là
c'est un choix qu'on a fait avec nos
équipes qui souhaitaient à arrêter
puisqu'on n'avait pas d'obligation de
fermer les activités après-vente de
réparation de mobiles qui sont
considérées comme des activités
essentielles nous avons à peu près 80 85
% des équipes qui sont en statue
activité partielle
ça représente à peu près 90 personnes
voire 100 personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
en activité partielle depuis le 17 mars
[Musique]
d'autres chiffres d'affaires il est il
est nul depuis le 17 mars
et il sera nulle pendant au moins un
mois voire six semaines donc vous
imaginez bien six semaines son chiffre
d'affaires ça fait entre 15 et 20% de
chiffre d'affaires en moins sur le
premier semestre
[Musique]
notre chance c'est qu'on a une
trésorerie suffisante aujourd'hui pour
faire face à cette période de
confinement après il faudra que nos
activités reprennent et qu'elle reprenne
un peu mieux que normalement puisque il
nous faudra essayer compenser au mieux 6
me ces quatre ou six semaines
d'inactivité pour conserver tous les
emplois évidemment c'est la priorité et
pour commander les moyens suffisants
également pour nos infrastructures et
tous les frais fixes qu'on a à supporter
vous le savez la crise sanitaire et le
confinement ont contraints à énormément
d'annulation notamment le marathon de
paris qui devait se tenir dimanche et
bien il en fallait plus pour les
coureurs du coeur c'est personnes qui
étaient inscrits au marathon pour
défendre les couleurs de l'association
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque on en parle
avec mathis poirier qui est avec nous
bonsoir mathis vous avez 19 ans vous
êtes originaire de neauphle-le-château
vous est confiné d'ailleurs actuellement
et vous vous apprêtez à relever un défi
ce sera dimanche courir le marathon
depuis votre domicile pour aider à
sauver des enfants qui sont malades
cardiaques
déjà c'était une évidence pour vous
malgré l'annulation du marathon de paris
ii quand même relever le défi de chez
vous tout à fait c'était très symbolique
c'est une action très symbolique a
réalisé pour l'association de tout de
même pour la courir ladurie d'humour at
on que l'on avait prévu c'était c'est
très important pour récolter plus de
dons pour sauver ses enfants
voilà pour pas que notre préparation
toi vaine et que l'on pourrait se
motiver pour la suite de l'aventuré va
s'étaler jusqu'à fin septembre pour le
marathon de paris
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque je leur
précise pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
c'est une ong qui permet à des enfants
de pays défavorisés souffrant de
malformations cardiaques de venir se
faire opérer
en france c'est important pour vous de
se joindre à ce combat d'aidé finalement
à sauver ces enfants qui sont malades
c'est très important surtout en ces
temps de crise ces associations ne se
nourrissent ma queue de que des dons
finalement c'est leur principale source
de revenus pour eux ces enfants donc
c'est très important qu'il y ait des
donateurs qu'ils puissent participer à
ce genre d'événements sportifs pour
allier le sport et le caritatif et
proulx et pouvoir assister on va dire
participer à la survie de ces enfants
qui ne peuvent malheureusement pas se
payer ce genre d'opération qui font
partie des opérations les plus chères
chirurgicalement alors votre marathon
depuis chez vous doit permettre
d'augmenter le montant de votre cagnotte
qui servira sauver ses enfants vous avez
actuellement à dépasser les 5000 euros
il faut douze mille euros pour permettre
une opération c'est ça une opération
coûte 2000 euros environ
c'est exactement ça en moyenne un enfant
pour coopération et puis pour l'ensemble
voilà des frais cela va coûter environ
12000 euros
il faut savoir que pour participer au
marathon de paris avec mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque il suffit de récolter 800
euros pour avoir son dossard solidaire
la majorité des des coureurs vont au
delà des objectifs pour contribuer le
plus possible à cet événement et et au
paiement de ses enfants
et donc voilà on est à deux jours de ce
défi quel est votre état d'esprit
aujourd'hui
très combatif suis très très motivé en
plus les beaux jours reviennent avec de
belles chaleurs
c'est dimanche donc ça va être très très
agréable départ il va sauter vers 9
heures donc ton père est très très douce
pète ça va être très sympa j'ai engagé
un jardin dans lequel je vais pouvoir
effectuer ce petit des films et je pense
phare voilà live sur les réseaux sociaux
pour pour montrer à tous les donateurs
qu'on est là pour relever ce challenge
j'allais vous demander justement le
parcours c'est vous allez rester dans le
jardin si vous allez passer un peu par
votre maison comment ça va se passer
vous rester uniquement dans le jardin
alors voilà l'objectif c'est de faire ta
donc de chez so pour montrer qu'on
continue à faire du sport et à défendre
des valeurs
caritative depuis chez soi en ces
périodes de confinement donc voilà c'est
ça je vais jouer et j'ai la chance
d'avoir un jardin
donc je vais pouvoir j'ai pouvoir on est
en rond on va dire faire des allers et
venues entre les arbres ça va être très
agréable la maison ça va être un peu
compliqué il ya toute famille de dame
nature mais mais voilà le jardin le
jaraaf va suffire et du coup la
préparation ça c'est fait aussi dans le
jardin depuis le début du confinement
j'imagine depuis le début du coup n'ont
heureusement on a le secteur et un
kilomètre qui nous permet de sortir
voilà en dessous d'une heure par jour
je cours pas tous les jours on va dire
une fois tous les deux jours moins d'une
heure à un kilomètre du domicile maximum
ça c'est plutôt on va dire avantageux ça
nous permet de continuer de nous
entraîner
même si c'est important de rester chez
soi on le sait et bien bravo pour cette
belle initiative
mathis on essaiera de prendre de nous de
vos nouvelles lundi après ce défi merci
à vous et bon courage aux 6,1 dans ce
confinement
merci beaucoup merci à vous et puis
avant de vous laisser ne manquez pas
tout à l'heure sur tv 60,18 ce
rendez-vous soirée live autour de best
tricks ce documentaire tourné en grande
partie dans les yvelines revient sur la
performance unique du verrier roi louis
boniface un triple salto arrière sur une
slackline une première et même un record
mondial documentaire suivie d'un échange
avec louis boniface et avec l équipe de
production la soirée et à retrouver à
partir de 20h35 voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale merci de votre
fidélité
restez chez vous et belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]
m